a companhia consegue ouvir mas mais ou
menos 100 não ok
a minha apresentação chamas relaxa nada
está sob controle é um caso diferente né
já me disseram que eu acho que está tudo
sob controle
mas eu aprendi nos últimos anos que
excita maneira de viver de uma parte fit
que estava há muito tempo e ajudou a
olhar para a vida de uma forma curiosa
em vez de decidir que a vida tem que ser
assim para eu estar feliz mas antes
vamos contar como eu consegui até lá
vamos perguntar se eu dissesse que vocês
todos aqui estão desligados de vocês
mesmos a maior parte você a delegada de
vocês mesmos e se eu dissesse que nós
todos desde pequenos aprendemos a usar
máscaras várias personas para podermos
viver na sociedade para nos defender
para podermos fazer parte de um grupo
para nos sentirmos aceitos
quem é que é que foi ensinado pequeno
que é bom é completo independentemente
daquilo que faz
isso fez ou não fez o dever se comportou
se bem não comportou se bateu na mãe não
bateu
todos nós vivemos com regras dos pais da
igreja da escola da sociedade e parece
tão fácil não é a força que tem uma
lista de preencher os requisitos e
quando estiverem preenchidos aí sim vai
sentir bem vai receber elogios todo
mundo vai ser uma pessoa bem sucedida
baixas aceita na sociedade e obrigou
renan a enganava supostamente s ser isso
mas agora pergunta é a seguinte o que
acontece quando as chamas carla ea
natureza dela não está nem nunca tinha
pensado em ser aquela rapariga prendada
ea natureza dela também 30 sabe aprender
a cozinhar o cruzeiro e na verdade a
natureza bela é mesmo andar de skate
subir a dar um espartilho a cabeça não
sei quantas vezes abrem os joelhos não
vai se casar
como é que o estádio
imaginem o que fazer com uma natureza
que o esporte é muito curiosa
independente e que é sempre aquilo que
está dentro dela
eu fui muitas vezes classificada e
quando fui castigado fisicamente por
palavras
foi pelas caras pelas ligações das
pessoas porque mais uma vez a carla não
conseguiu preencher os outros índios que
haviam no bar rolim e mail e fax ep
disse a morena
e assim muito cedo comecei a desenvolver
em mim mesma a voz que vivia há algo bem
contigo porque existe uma lista de
coisas pra fazer êxito não consegue
comportar esta lista não tem lá um dia
e foi esse tema que foi comigo foi
comigo esse tema não vou fugir da degola
mas não fugi de casa fugir
fui estudar porque se eu conseguir fazer
aqui um curso de direito na áfrica do
sul que é melhor que angola certeza como
me senti bem ao clube grená mas é aos 19
anos quando fui embora já tenha tornado
eu a pior crítica de mim mesma como diz
o do miguel ruiz venceu com 5 por isso
aqui não consigo um livro que não mudou
muito a minha vida que eles os quatro
foram alimentos
os quatro acordos diz que a explicação é
tão poderosa que num determinado momento
da nossa vida já não precisamos que
ninguém domestica não precisamos que o
vaiou a escola a igreja nos nomes de
quem estamos tão bem treinados que somos
nós o próximo de uma dor
somos um animal ao todo modificado agora
os dois ficamos nós mesmos
segundo um sistema de crenças que nos
transmitiram utilizando o mesmo sistema
do castigo não compensa
já chegamos a nós mesmos e premiamos
quando somos um menino bom
uma menina boa e foi assim que eu fui
pra quem tá e fiz o meu curso à espera
de ter minado por cento e finalmente o
que é afinal a morenaça agora sim sou
bom o suficiente mas não sentir uma
amiga com quem
envia disse olha eu faço canoagem mas
acho que não vai gostar é difícil
ela disse que é difícil porque de fato é
difícil equilibrar o barco mas a minha
cabeça vi o ronaldo que nasça e eu pra
mostrar que era ordenado já tinha
aprendido que nesta vida tem que lutar
com tudo e todos
entre entrei para a canoagem e fui para
o campeonato fui parar em campeonatos
mundiais
talvez se eu fosse urinar em curso
agora só atleta foi o campeonato mundial
agora vou sempre lutar holllywood na
nota o elenco e depois fui para a
holanda
agora talvez sair de áfrica e fosse na
europa obviamente mais moderna talvez aí
fim com o sentimento que terminado o meu
mestrado
aí sim você governar e fui e graduei
acumulada ea etapa mais bela
terminei meu modo de ver navio e fui
trabalhar com o tribunal da iugoslávia
após cortes internacionais tribunal da
holanda começou com o céu a um quadro
gado de mais advogados
eu noto que ele nasceu e foi essa mesma
sensação que permitiu casar com alguém
com quem eu nunca devia ter casado
porque não tinha mostrado já tinha
mostrado por a mais ver que eu não
tínhamos as mesmas formas de pensar e
viver a vida
mas na minha cabeça na minha função da
nota o gre nal eu pensei eu já tenho uma
lista quase completa
talvez se eu preencher uma desse produto
vitor
com 29 anos em casar então aí talvez
bastante não é treinar mas olha
infelizmente não casei me e que
aconteceu parecia levar uma vida por
fora parecia perfeita tenho um marido
que parecia ser fantástico tem um
emprego estava a ganhar um bom dinheiro
estava no masculino um tribunal
internacional do gabarito
a advogada carla mas então e aqui dentro
vazio e porque estava virou tenha
dinheiro ia de férias ea torcida e
parecia estar mais feliz do mundo mas
não estava mas não sabia por que em 2011
o barco começou a rachar
comecei a ficar muito deprimida mas como
africana aprendi que o tomar luca how to
saudável que de noah
aqui não há que isso pressão
eu lembro uma amiga uma amiga africana
dizer a uma planta com uma doença
holandesa o que é a depressão o que bixo
mostra muito bem como é que uma pessoa
aprendeu que segue deprimido o que é
isso porque tudo por mim eu tenho tudo
supostamento fiz isto preenche todos os
projetos dentro daquela lista e por que
eu não me sinto bem porque eu não sou
feliz porque eu não sou duro na rua é
maior do que o ordenado que o barco
começou a gastar em 2011 fiquem no
primeiro da minha tireóide foi de férias
meu corpo deixou de funcionar e então o
psi e agora e eu sempre fui musculosa eu
sempre fui atleta e de repente não
consigo ser então eu não sou atleta do
que eu sou quem eu sou e depois que eu
fiz conseguiu fugir fugir dos da vida da
advogada apresentar uma proposta para
quem são onde eu podia trabalhar como
treinador do cross feito talvez vá pôr
os pés não tem nada a ver se consigo a
mulher um bocadinho não tiver muito fria
tiro e lá fui eu para a capital ea
corrupção
fui muito bem recebida no meu trabalho
disse bom talvez seja possível viver sem
ser advogada mas o que eu vou dizer os
meus pais e eles pagaram tanto para
fazer isso e será divulgado e centro de
ginástica
mas o que fazer se a mãe natureza
chamava pra isso tem que ter um ganho o
campeonato africano cross feito ano
passado e fui pro campeonato mundial em
califórnia e foi o maior da minha vida
então tem que deixar de ser advogado mas
é treinadora do profeta mas quando
voltei estava tão jornada deixando
conseguir fazer muitas coisas
o meu casamento explodiu na minha cara
de uma forma mais rigorosa possível e
então ficou não sou advogada não sou
atleta já não estou casada na sua mulher
do flamengo então
e agora o meu gps desligado porque
branca minha vida toda o meu gps estão
aqui a falar comigo mas queda mais à
esquerda mas eu
todo mundo dizia que a direita que havia
dois em tribunal foi então como é que eu
faço então desliguei o gps deixei de
escutá lo e fui pra direita e entre um
acidente muito grande
vida vazia fica zangada substituto uma
coisa que vem teremos um prédio de tal
maneira que pegaram e me puseram acima
no lugar de percepções malucas porque eu
tinha perdido completamente a noção de
quem é e quem não era problema e fiquei
tão zangada tão zangada tão zangada que
parecia que andava com uma moto ficou
estava zangada com tudo e com todos e
chegou uma altura felizmente uma vida é
bondosa apresentou uma amiga não diz olá
tomada em vítima
tudo que aconteceu aqui nessa tua vida
funções tuas tusco ler fiz tudo o que eu
estava louca então eu queria isto mas
felizmente apresentou uma pessoa um
senhor com o senhor de portugal chamado
emídio carvalho em milho feijão tantas
perguntas
emídio destruiu a imagem que eu tinha de
mim mesma e mimos tomo que não são as
coisas não são as coisas que eu faço não
são as coisas que eu tenho criança carla
me ensinou a voltar pra pessoa para quem
o gps que eu tenha errado estava todo
enferrujado todo oito coitadinho game e
pudim e me disse uma coisa que achei
muito bonita e queria compartilhar com
vocês eu disse que nesta vida não só
sofremos porque nós temos a mania que
todos os banheiros os modelos quando há
muito vento nem quando dão se mal
agora o capitão ninguém liga nenhuma
aquilo vai com a vida realmente mantém
sair durante muitos anos e nós sofremos
porque na verdade não sabemos quem somos
aprendemos que para viver para sermos
bem sucedidos temos que olhar pra fora
não presidente para quem somos nós então
vivemos e morremos uma vida sem saber
quem somos em sua casa mas o que ela
quer e quais são os valores da carla e
alice
a vida é tão bondosa nós sofremos quando
lutamos por ela com ela uma pergunta que
ele fez que eu achei muito importante
foi que carla mesmo agora quito
qual é a coisa que mais férias na altura
desfilando tal foi um diálogo bandido
não sei que alguém
leal será que isso é verdade e
obviamente que eu peguei uma lista das
coisas deviam que ela é desleal
ele só que agora vamos trocar isso
estuda em 7 eu fui desleal comigo mesmo
fugindo emídio últimas duas semanas não
quis responder porque era algo que
estava muito perto de mim como eu fui
desleal comigo mesmo mas aí estava o meu
parei de lutar
fui de facto de ver como eu mesma fui
desleal porque apesar de ser um monte na
minha vida indicaram que o gps tarde à
esquerda da esquerda eu fui desviar
porque fui pra direita
pude ver comigo mesma quando fica
sabendo que alguém que mostrou por a
mais b que não era pessoa de bem estar
comigo fui desleal comigo mesma quando o
meu corpo de um dos sinais que eu andar
por aí fui desviar por que não descobrir
quem era eu mas também não sabia como
fazer e eu disse sim e então como seria
sua vida se eu não acreditasse que as
pessoas não têm que ser leais também
seria livre então deve ser livre
as pessoas são os que são a única coisa
que pode controlar isto e mesmo assim
nem tudo controla porque nem toda a
inspiração controla
então esse não trocaram se eu fui
desleal comigo mesma
o que pode fazer diferente posso ser
leal comigo mesmo é o que significa isso
na vida da canoa hoje significa que
alguém faz algo e eu já tenho essa
pessoa em vez de acusar essa pessoa eu
pergunto ok
o que se sabe o que essa pessoa mostrar
mostrar a mim eu não quero ver em mim
mesma o que está acontecendo aqui à
minha volta que eu não quero aceitar a
mesma então reverter tornando uma
batalha um lugar onde eu luto todos os
dias a vida tornou-se algo para encarar
comum que vai acontecer agora e amanhã o
que quer para fazer é ver se tornar uma
batalha tornou-se algo em que a
curiosidade deste caso não matou o gato
na curiosa até acordou inspirado ea vida
tornou diferente hoje não tem
absolutamente nada
mas a coisa mais importante que eu tenho
aqui hoje sei quem sou e eu em
dependentemente do caos que tiver a
minha volta
rocha por caos pós parto a vida a vida é
bondosa vida é para ser vivida e ela é
que define o que acontece conosco branco
olha a cantar